indeed it's been a bloody round and this
was a bloody game
and uh this you can be proud of the way
you conducted this attack of f4 and pure
domination your thoughts uh on how you
played oh thank you i think it was a
pretty smooth game
i don't think um it was too complicated
for me to find the moves
so i really enjoyed it
where did she go wrong
i really think that she allowed me all
to develop all that attack on the king
side
so maybe uh
she concentrated too much on the queen
side
yeah we're seeing here she let your pawn
get to e4 and then you got
this move e5 and then she went a bit
defensive
seemed like you just very nicely avoided
anything she was doing right and went
about your own business maybe she should
have played um a 4b5 like typical idea
um well not with queen on c5 but overall
before quincy five just go with b5 idea
maybe that was more typical for the game
right the way she played she got nothing
on that side and then you just i was
able to block all that attack
and put my pieces nicely in the king
side uh but i think g3
maybe
just to interrupt you for a second
wesley has won his game and is joining
the leading pack with sam sebastian for
the moment
with all the games pending
sorry uh let's get back to this position
right here you
is this the way the game went yes
f4 and you soccer you play knight
on g2 correct i sacrificed on g2
you have been playing very quickly
throughout the tournament anna
and uh i'm sure you're aware you have a
lot of uh
time trouble mismanagement players in
the event
and here you actually paused because you
were probably considering e3 and we were
we were thinking that both moves were
really
good for you
you chose knight g2 how did you weigh
the scales and how did you come to the
decision not to play e3 because maurice
who he loves a spectacular win which you
found uh he he turned to becoming an e3
person that he would have played e3 why
did you choose knight g2
over e3
you know actually you're correct that um
i was thinking for a while here
trying to choose
i just felt more comfortable with knight
g2 because i thought
maybe it was more secure okay
maybe that's the reason but
i felt like both moves were equally
uh i once played boris baskey when i
asked him that question he said i was
mentally flipping a coin
okay
well when you ask when you ask women we
can say we're checking our intuition
yeah okay and your intuition told you
knight g2 is the way to go and of course
f5 was your main move that you had
calculated as well that's right and then
tell us what tell us how the game
how you were feeling what was going on
well after this i knew i was winning it
was just a matter of finding the right
moves
and you played h4 driving yeah the
pieces backwards that's right and i i
think after rook of fade it's
just absolutely winning
i was extolling the fact that your
bishop on d5 was so powerful
i mean just controlling
especially with the king on h1 right
yeah yeah yeah this is uh
as you say very very last try trying to
win material but this is going to
actually get her mated when she takes
the queen
your tournament has been kind of
interesting
we've seen a loss we've seen a lot of
draws how you feeling about how you're
playing overall
well you know i'm not gonna uh try to
convince you it's so easy after not
playing for a while right
so
uh well it takes a lot right a lot of
preparation a lot of effort um but i'm
really enjoying it
uh because i think at this point uh i
can tell i play chess
it's my hobby in life i'm not doing it
professionally so i really enjoy what
i'm doing well you can enjoy this win
for sure congratulations let's hope to
see some more good luck with the rest of
the games well done anna for sure and we
mentioned once again west